This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. But please, call me Ishmael. In the basement archives of the new Bedford Whaling Museum in Massachusetts, there's a lot that catches the eye. This is a nice collection of mounted harpoons and lances, so... Michael Dyer is the museum's curator of maritime history. This particular harpoon is an early toggle type, but once you plant this thing into the blubber of sperm whale, it'll pop open like that and lock into place under that blubber.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。但请叫我以实玛利。在马萨诸塞州新贝德福德捕鲸博物馆的地窖档案馆里，有很多引人注目的东西。这是一个精美的装裱鱼叉和长矛收藏，所以……迈克尔·戴尔是该博物馆的海事历史馆长。这把特殊的鱼叉是早期的活动扣式鱼叉，但一旦你把这东西钉进抹香鲸的鲸脂里，它就会像那样弹开，并在该鲸脂下锁定到位。
The shelves are lined with rusting harpoons and whale exploding bombs. These weapons were used for killing whales quickly and efficiently. The victims of those weapons are lying around too, parts of them at least. That's a reporter, Daniel Ackerman. What is this? That's a metal wall tusk. It's all kind of strange stuff back here, I don't even know what it is. In the 1800s, whaling was a vast and brutal industry,
架子上摆满了生锈的鱼叉和捕鲸爆炸弹。这些武器曾被用于快速、高效地杀死鲸鱼。这些武器的受害者也散落各处，至少是它们的一部分。那是记者丹尼尔·阿克曼。这是什么？那是一个金属墙壁獠牙。这里到处都是这种奇怪的东西，我甚至不知道它是什么。在19世纪，捕鲸是一个庞大而残酷的行业，
sometimes as deadly for the sailors involved as it was for the whales. And the Global Epoch Center of Whaling was just two blocks down from the museum on the pier's jutting out into New Bedford Harbor. I mean, you're talking 350 vessels in the mid 1850s were registered and sailed out of New Bedford. That's a huge fleet.
有时对涉事的船只水手来说，和对鲸鱼一样致命。而全球捕鲸纪元中心距离博物馆只有两个街区，就在伸入新贝德福德港的防波堤上。我的意思是，在1850年代中期，你说有350艘船只在新贝德福德注册并起航。那是一个庞大的船队。
So, they're sailing all around the world. They're taking more than half a million animals throughout the 19th century were extracted from the seas by American railing fleet. All this slaughter wasn't because people had some insatiable appetite for whale meat. It was all about things people could make out of whale plumber. In the archives, Dyer picks up a jar full of what looks like melted chocolate bars. This is this whale oil soap I was talking about. Soap that 150 years ago, someone made by hacking the blubber off a whale and boiling it. It works great too. Have you used it? Yes, I have. I actually asked permission from
所以，它们在世界各地航行。在整个19世纪，美国捕鲸船队从海里捕捞了超过五十万头动物。所有这些屠杀并不是因为人们对鲸肉有什么饕餮般的胃口。这一切都是为了人们可以用鲸脂制作的东西。在档案馆里，戴尔拿起了一个罐子，里面装满了看起来像融化巧克力棒的东西。这就是我刚才说的鲸油肥皂。150年前，有人把鲸鱼的鲸脂砍下来煮沸制成的肥皂。它也很好用。你用过吗？是的，我用过。我其实征得了
and we talked about it in the department and I said like wash my hands with some of this stuff and did and it lathered up and it was great. Another major driver of the whaling industry, besides dirty hands, was darkness. This is pretty awesome what the whaling industry, besides dirty hands, was darkness. This is pretty awesome what the whaling industry is all about, you know. Dyer picks up a clear glass lamp, cast like an ornate goblet, and it's filled with amber-colored whale oil. This is high-quality 19th century lighting. When you think today, you know, you throw on your light switch, whatever, you get all the light that you want. That wasn't the way life was. you get all the light that you want. That wasn't the way life was.
我们在部门里谈过这件事，我说用这东西洗洗手，照做了，起泡了，效果很好。捕鲸业的另一个主要驱动因素，除了弄脏双手，就是黑暗。关于捕鲸业到底是关于什么的，这真的很酷，你知道的。戴尔拿起一盏透明的玻璃灯，造型像一个华丽的高脚杯，里面装满了琥珀色的鲸油。这是高质量的19世纪照明设备。当你今天想到，你知道的，你啪地打开电灯开关，随便怎样，你就能得到所有你想要的亮光。生活可不是那样的。你就能得到所有你想要的亮光。生活可不是那样的。
Before the electric light bulb or petroleum burning lamps, whale oil provided the best lighting money could buy. It burned bright and smoke-free. Whale oil rendered in New Bedford was sold to light street lamps, homes, and businesses all over the world. The city even adopted the Latin motto, Lucom De Vundo, which means, I spread light.
在电灯泡或石油燃烧灯出现之前，鲸油提供了金钱能买到的最好的照明。它燃烧明亮且没有烟雾。在新贝德福德提炼的鲸油被卖来照亮世界各地的路灯、家庭和企业。这座城市甚至采用了拉丁语座右铭“Lucom De Vundo”，意思是“我传播光明”。
The phrase can still be seen stamped on the sidewalks outside of city hall. But fancy lamps and throwback soaps aren't what brought me to the whaling museum today. I came to see some much smaller artifacts. Tucked away in the back corner of the archives is an unmarked gray cabinet holding perhaps the most consequential items in the entire collection.
这个短语至今仍能在市政厅外的人行道上看到被压印出来。但精美的灯具和复古肥皂并不是今天把我带到捕鲸博物馆的原因。我是来看一些更小的文物的。藏在档案馆最里面角落的是一个没有标记的灰色柜子，里面装着整个收藏中最具有决定性的物品。
Inside sit row after row of tiny glass bottles plugged with tiny wooden corks. There's a lot of bottles of oil down here. Gun on. Some machine oil. This is from the US Navy. This is torpedo gyroscope oil. Not every bottle is so specific. Dyer reads the list of intended uses off one of them. Using the bathroom, bicycles, bolts, cameras, carriages, cash registers, tap-hands, chisels, clippers, cutlery, doors, dent...
里面是一排排塞着微小木质软木塞的小玻璃瓶。这里有很多油瓶。机油。有些是机器油。这是来自美国海军的。这是鱼雷陀螺仪油。并非每个瓶子都这么具体。戴尔读着其中一个瓶子上的用途清单。用卫生间、自行车、螺栓、相机、马车、收银机、水龙头手柄、凿子、剪刀、餐具、门、齿轮……
These unassuming bottles of oil hold the history of a hidden technology, lubrication, that keeps the rest of our technology humming smoothly along. It locks in motor's musical instruments and household articles. So everything? Sure. Sure. In the story of how lubrication became a technology unto itself, starts with dead whales and piles of cold hard cash.
这些不起眼的油瓶里装着一项隐藏技术的历史——润滑，正是它让我们的其余技术顺利运转。它锁在电动机、乐器和家居用品中。所以什么都是？当然。当然。在讲述润滑如何成为一门独立的技术的故事中，始于死去的鲸鱼和成堆冰冷坚硬的现金。
In the 1800s, Whaling transformed New Bedford from a sleepy fishing town into one of the wealthiest cities in the world. Fruitful whaling voyages built vast fortunes for the merchants and financiers who ran the industry. Society, men and women strutted through towns sporting the latest trends in European fashion, and colorful Victorian mansions sprang up by the dozens. All built with that sweet, sweet whale money. As Herman Melville put it in Moby Dick, these brave houses and flowery gardens came from the Atlantic Pacific Indian oceans. What an all. They were harpooned and dragged up hither
在19th世纪，捕鲸将新贝德福德从一个沉睡的渔村变成了世界上最富有的城市之一。硕果累累的捕鲸航行为经营该行业的商人和金融家积累了巨大的财富。社会上，男男女女穿着欧洲最新潮流的服装在镇上招摇过市，色彩斑斓的维多利亚式豪宅成栋地涌现出来。全都是用那些甜美迷人的鲸鱼钱建造的。正如赫尔曼·梅尔维尔在《白鲸》中所写的那样，这些勇敢的房子和繁花似锦的花园来自大西洋、太平洋、印度洋。多么丰富的捕获。它们被鱼叉叉住并从海底拖到这里
from the bottom of the sea. It was like a gold rush. The whaling industry pulled in anyone looking to make a quick buck. And one of those people was a local new bed for businessman named William F.9. Nye was something of a serial entrepreneur. He had dabbled in everything from selling fruit to building church organs. And like just about everyone in town, he looked to Wales for his next big score. Nye realized there were already plenty of people
上来。这就像是一场淘金热。捕鲸业吸引了任何想赚快钱的人。其中一个人是新贝德福德的本地商人，名叫威廉·F·奈。奈可以说是某种连续创业者。他涉足过从卖水果到建造教堂风琴的各种行业。而且就像镇上的几乎所有人一样，他把目光投向了鲸鱼，寻找他的下一次大丰收。奈意识到已经有很多人
hawking new Bedford whale oil for lamps, and so those markets were saturated. But in 1865, he found a new way to sell whales to the world. Here to explain is one of William Nye's living relatives. My brother has a bottle of Nye whale whale. That's well over a century old. By way of introduction, for those of us who grew up watching educational television in the 90s, how might we know you?
在兜售新贝德福德的灯用鲸油，所以这些市场已经饱和了。但在1865年，他找到了向世界销售鲸鱼的新方法。威廉·奈的一位在世亲属来解释这一点。我弟弟有一瓶奈氏鲸油。那已经有一个多世纪的历史了。作为介绍，对于我们这些在90年代看着教育电视台长大的人来说，我们怎么可能会认识你？
Oh, I'm Bill Nye, the science guy, did a show we did a hundred episodes about science. And before Bill Nye was the science guy, he was an aerospace engineer. All right, so you have like first-hand experience. Oh man, I first had the mechanical engineer. I'm all about lubricants, man. And here's how Bill Nye, the mechanical engineer guy, thinks about motion. When you have any sliding mechanical parts, in general, you need a lubricant. And why is that?
哦，我是“科学怪人”比尔·奈，我们做了一个关于科学的一百集的节目。而在比尔·奈成为科学怪人之前，他是一名航空航天工程师。好吧，所以你有第一手的经验。哦天哪，我首先是机械工程师。我全心投入润滑剂，伙计。以下是身为机械工程师的比尔·奈对运动的看法。当你拥有任何滑动机械部件时，总的来说，你需要润滑剂。这是为什么呢？
Wow, because things are rough. Things are rough out there, man. And by that, I mean, even surfaces that look smooth actually have roughness. Two rough surfaces rubbing against each other causes friction. So friction is the force we feel whenever things are rubbing on your... And these problems aren't anything new. Julius Caesar and those guys were lubricating their axles with grease, and you would get grease from by rendering animal fat. When archaeologists opened the more than 3,000-year-old tomb of Egyptian pharaoh Tutankhamen,
哇，因为事情很粗糙。外面情况很粗糙，伙计。我的意思是，即使是看起来光滑的表面实际上也有粗糙度。两个粗糙表面相互摩擦会产生摩擦力。所以摩擦力是我们每当有东西在你的……时感受到的力。这些问题并不是什么新鲜事。尤利乌斯·恺撒和那些家伙过去常常用油脂润滑他们的车轴，你可以通过提炼动物脂肪来获得油脂。当考古学家打开拥有3000多年历史的埃及法老图坦卡蒙的陵墓时，
they found half a dozen horse-drawn chariots, and on the bottom of those chariots, they found animal fat. Slathered into the spot where the wheels rotate around the axle, this helped control the friction problem. Instead of the wooden wheels grinding against the wooden axle with thousands of pounds per square inch of pressure, the wheels would glide gently around a film of animal grace, providing a smooth, efficient ride fit for a fero. So by introducing a layer of oil that can tolerate these very high pressures, things get slippery.
他们发现了六辆马车，在那些马车的底部，他们找到了动物脂肪。涂抹在车轮绕着车轴旋转的地方，这有助于控制摩擦问题。木制车轮不是以每平方英寸数千磅的压力与木制车轴相磨损，而是围绕着一层动物油脂滑行，为法老提供了平稳、高效的骑乘体验。因此，通过引入一层能够承受这些极高压力的油膜，事情变得滑溜了。
And it's a wonderful feature of our mechanical world. You just can't get much done without lubricants, and you guys can make all the puns you want and all the innuendo you want. And for a long time, that's just how things got done. Machines were lubricated with whatever local material was lying around. Animal fat, that's oil, sometimes just water or mud. But then... The industrial revolution was the great discontinuity of modern history.
这是我们机械世界的一个奇妙特征。没有润滑剂，你简直无法完成太多工作，你们可以随意进行各种双关语和影射。在很长一段时间里，事情就是这样完成的。机器是用手头任何周围的当地材料进行润滑的。动物脂肪，也就是油，有时只是水或泥土。但是……工业革命是现代历史上的巨大断层。
By 1800, there were already a thousand steam engines in operation in England. The industrial revolution brought an explosion of new kinds of machinery. Factories sprung up, brimming with steam engines and spinning machines and looms, everything newer, bigger and faster, and all of it in need of lubrication. And suddenly, whatever peanut oil was lying around was no longer good enough to keep the modern mechanical world moving at top speed. The 1800s saw a wave of patents for new kinds of lubricant. These were not materials just plucked out of nature, but refined and mixed together. There were blends of graphite in lard, of olive oil, with rock dust.
到1800年，英国已经有一千台蒸汽机在运转。工业革命带来了新种类机械的爆发。工厂如雨后春笋般涌现，到处都是蒸汽机、纺织机和织布机，一切都更新、更大、更快，所有这些都需要润滑。突然之间，周围随便什么花生油都不再足够好，无法保持现代机械世界以最高速度运转。19世纪见证了一波针对新类型润滑剂的专利浪潮。这些不仅仅是从自然界中摘取的材料，而是经过提炼和混合的。有石墨和猪油的混合物，橄榄油和岩尘的混合物。
It was a world full of friction. Scientists and engineers were racing to design quality lubrication for it, and William F. Nye realized that there was something special about the oil from those giant marine mammals landing in the port of New Bedford. Whale oil is a very high-performance lubricant, and by that I mean it maintains its lubricity at different temperatures. Basically, it stays slippery and doesn't congeal in the cold like other oils. Oil from sperm whales was a particularly good all-temperature lubricant. Sperm whales live everywhere from the equator all the way to the edge of the sea ice
这是一个充满摩擦的世界。科学家和工程师们竞相为其设计优质的润滑剂，威廉·F·奈意识到，从新贝德福德港上岸的那些巨型海洋哺乳动物身上提取的油有着特殊之处。鲸油是一种高性能润滑剂，我的意思是它在不同温度下都能保持其润滑性。基本上，它保持滑润，不像其他油那样在寒冷中凝固。抹香鲸的油是一种特别好的全温润滑剂。抹香鲸生活在从赤道一直到北极和南极海冰边缘的各个地方，
in both the Arctic and Antarctic. Whale oil is also non-corrosive. It doesn't wear down metals. A vital quality given the proliferation of metal machinery at the time. By all accounts, the opulent city of New Bedford stunk of rotting whale. But to nigh, it was the putrid stench of opportunity. In 1865, he began refining whale oil in his kitchen and bottling it as a lubricant.
鲸油也具有非腐蚀性。它不会磨损金属。鉴于当时金属机械的大量激增，这是一项至关重要的品质。据各方所述，富裕的新贝德福德市散发着腐烂鲸鱼的恶臭。但对奈来说，那是充满机会的恶臭。1865年，他开始在自己的厨房里提炼鲸油，并将其作为润滑剂装瓶出售。
Many of his first customers were whalers themselves. He sold the refined oil from sperm whales and some other species as a lubricant for timepieces, including cronometers. Those machines helped ships navigate at sea, often for years on end. As Michael Dyer of the Whaling Museum puts it, if that cronometer went haywire.
他的许多第一批客户都是捕鲸人本身。他将从抹香鲸和其他一些物种中提炼出的油作为钟表（包括航海钟）的润滑剂出售。这些机器帮助船只在海上航行，通常一连好几年。正如捕鲸博物馆的迈克尔·戴尔所说，如果那个航海钟出了故障。
You could lose your ship and everybody on it and the entire it and the entire cargo and everything. So it has to work. And it did thanks in part to William Nies all weather lubricant. He successfully expanded the market for whale based products beyond lamp lighting and the occasional bar of soap. He moved his refining operation from his kitchen into a storefront and eventually into an entire factory where he could make lubrication for all the new fangled machines coming to the American home. Nye wasn't the only one refining whale oil into lubricant.
你可能会失去你的船、船上的每个人、整整一船货物以及一切。所以它必须正常工作。它确实做到了，这部分要归功于威廉·奈的全天候润滑剂。他成功地将基于鲸鱼的产品的市场扩展到了灯火照明和偶尔的一块肥皂之外。他将他的提炼业务从厨房搬到了店面，最终搬进了一座整栋工厂，在那里他可以为进入美国家庭的所有新奇机器制造润滑剂。奈并不是唯一一个将鲸油提炼成润滑剂的人。
He even had a cross-town rival in New Bedford, Ezra Kelly, who was known for his watch oil. But it was Nye who had the idea to specialize, to engineer a unique refining process for each application of lubricant. He made a super fine lubricant just for music boxes, and a thicker one just for firearms. For every machine, a lubricant.
他在新贝德福德甚至还有一个势均力敌的对手埃兹拉·凯利，他以其手表油而闻名。但正是奈有了专业化的想法，为每一种润滑剂应用设计独特的提炼工艺。他专门为八音盒制作了一种超细润滑剂，为枪械制作了一种较厚的润滑剂。每台机器，都有一个润滑剂。
Guy led the charge of oil refiners who applied the principles of chemistry, physics, and engineering to the problem of friction. And the oil refineries were very deliberate craftspeople who were applying specialized and proprietary knowledge to the processing of these animals to make a product that was unique to their business so that they could actually put it on the label. This is the greatest lubricant in the world. And that's exactly what Nye did. He wasn't just an engineer, but also something of a showboat on the marketing front.
盖伊领导了油品精炼商的潮流，他们将化学、物理和工程原理应用于摩擦问题。油品精炼商是非常审慎的工匠，他们将专业和专有的知识应用于这些动物的加工，以制造出对其业务而言独一无二的产品，这样他们就可以真正将其贴上标签。这是世界上最棒的润滑剂。这正是奈所做的。他不仅是一名工程师，而且在营销方面也有点爱炫耀。
One of his company's salesmen was known to end his pitches by drinking from a bottle of lubricant to prove how pure it was. Nye hawked his whale oil as a cure all for anything with moving parts. He displayed it at the world's Colombian exposition in Chicago in 1893. Four years later, he showed up in New York to pitch his specially oil for a new form of
他的公司的一位销售人员以通过喝一瓶润滑剂来证明其纯度而闻名，以此来结束他的推销。奈将他的鲸油作为任何有运动部件的万灵药来兜售。他在1893年芝加哥世界哥伦比亚博览会上展出了它。四年后，他出现在纽约，在麦迪逊广场花园举办的第一届全国自行车展上，为一种新型两轮交通工具推销他专门的油。
two-wheeled transport at the first National Bike Show at Madison Square Garden. By 1900, Nye had started experimenting with lubricant from different sources, like olive oil and meat's foot oil made from cattle bones. His specialty though remained his high end whale oil, which he shipped to eager customers all over the world. Now I had accomplished what he set out to do, open up a whole new market for whale based products, and make a ton of money doing it. But the early decades of the 20th century brought what we know today as supply chain issues. Through decades of overfishing, New Bedford's whalers had harpooned themselves in the foot, whales grew scarce, and ships had to chase their remaining prey farther and farther out to
到1900年，奈已经开始尝试来自不同来源的润滑剂，比如橄榄油和用牛骨头制作的牛脚油。不过他的特色依然是他高端的鲸油，他将其运送给世界各地的热切客户。现在，奈已经完成了他着手要做的事情：为基于鲸鱼的产品开辟了一个全新的市场，并在这样做中赚取了大量的钱。但是20世纪的前几十年带来了我们今天所知道的供应链问题。经过几十年的过度捕捞，新贝德福德的捕鲸人搬起石头砸了自己的脚，鲸鱼变得稀少，船只不得不跑得越来越远去追捕剩下的猎物。
sea. The last whaling ship from New Bedford Harbor sailed in 1927, the city's once-colourful mansions fell into drab disrepair and nice supply of raw materials largely dried up. The market for lubricants was taken over by cheaper petroleum-based products. As with all petroleum products, lubricating oil comes from crude oil. Crude oil, a veritable black magic that is taken from the depths of the earth. For its part, Nye lubricants kept scrounging whale oil, however it could, often relying
新贝德福德港的最后艘捕鲸船于1927年起航，这座城市曾经丰富多彩的豪宅陷入了单调失修的境地，奈的原材料供应也大体枯竭了。润滑剂市场被更便宜的石油基产品接管。与所有石油产品一样，润滑油来自原油。原油，一种从地球深处取出的真正的黑魔法。就其本身而言，奈氏润滑剂公司无论如何一直在搜寻鲸油，通常依靠有时搁浅在马萨诸塞州海岸领航鲸。但那些偶尔的搁浅根本不够。到了20世纪中叶，这家曾经挤满几十名工人的公司工厂，缩减到只有四名员工。奈氏润滑剂的终结似乎近在眼前。大规模生产的石油基润滑剂赢得了胜利。今天，整个世界都在薄薄一层润滑油上运转。油是我们的飞毯，没有它，任何车轮都无法转动，任何运动部件都无法操作。
on pilot whales that sometimes beech to themselves along the Massachusetts coast. But those occasional strandings just weren't enough. By the mid-1900s, the company's factory, once bustling with dozens of workers, dwindled to just four employees. It seemed the end was Nigh for Nile lubricant. Mass-produced petroleum-based lubricants had won the day. Today, the whole world moves on a thin film of lubricating oil. Oil is our magic carpet, without it no wheel could turn, no moving part operating.
石油产品对气候极其糟糕，对生活在炼油厂附近的居民有毒，但作为润滑剂，它们有很多优点。它们便宜，可以由石油公司大规模生产，并且不需要进行九死一生、历时多年的远航去追逐一头难以捉摸的白鲸。但这并不意味着石油公司可以大规模生产润滑剂，就代表这些润滑剂能完美工作。1966年，一位名叫彼得·乔斯的英国工程师发表了一篇论文，这篇论文将成为他所命名的这个小而不断增长的研究领域的宪章——摩擦学，即研究摩擦、磨损和润滑的学科。
Petroleum products were terrible for the climate and toxic for people living near refineries, but as lubricants, they had a lot going for them. They were cheap and they could be mass produced by oil companies, and they didn't require death-defying years-long voyages and pursuit of an elusive white whale. But just because oil companies could make lubricants on this massive scale, doesn't mean those lubricants worked perfectly. In 1966, a British engineer named Peter Joes published a paper that would become
摩擦学规则。没错，比尔·奈。直到今天，如果你走进一个摩擦学会议，你敢打赌人们一定在谈论所谓的“乔斯报告”。该论文衡量了摩擦对英国经济的字面成本。
the Constitution for the small but growing field of research he dubbed, Tribology, the study of friction, wear, and lubrication. Tribology rules. That's right, Bill Nye. To this day, if you walk into a Trology conference, you can bet people are talking about the so-called Joe's report. The paper measured the literal cost of friction to the British economy.
研究发现，由于润滑不良导致的机械不必要磨损，拖累了国家的生产力，相当于GDP的1%以上，相当于数十亿美元。看到这些结果，中国、美国和德国等国家纷纷竞相研究各自经济体中的磨损情况，他们都得出了类似的结论。我们需要更好的润滑剂。鲸鱼做不到这一点，石油也做不到。连科学怪人本人也承认，科学事实上并没有解决摩擦问题。让这些油和润滑剂分子在被挤压时不分解是一门黑魔法，伙计，这是一件棘手的事情。
It found that unnecessary wear and tear to machinery caused by bad lubrication was dragging down the nation's productivity by more than 1% of GDP, the equivalent of billions of dollars. Seeing these results, countries like China, Germany, and the US all raced to study wear and tear in their own economies, and they all came to similar conclusions. We need better lubricants. Wales didn't quite do it, neither did petroleum. Even the science guy himself admits that science had not in fact solved the problem of friction. Getting these molecules of oil of lubricant to not break down when they're smushed is a dark art, man, it's the tricky business.
好吧，所以这是一个得伟电钻。妮可·迪姆布罗西奥是现代黑魔法润滑剂的实践者。所以我们制造了一种进入齿轮箱随着它旋转的润滑剂。她站在她工作的润滑剂公司的销售室里，从陈列柜里拿物品。我们这里有一个吸入器。
All right, so this is a de-Walt drill. Nicole Diembrosio is a modern day per ver of the dark art of lubrication. So we make a lubricant that goes into the gearbox as it spins. She's standing in the sales room of the lubrication company she works for, pulling items from a display case. We have an inhaler in here.
里面有一种润滑剂，当你按下吸入器的顶部以获得一剂药物时，它会进入机械装置。这里还有一个用于胰岛素应用的药物输送装置。这个很重要，因为涉及一针。迪姆布罗西奥是一家至今仍被称为“奈氏润滑剂”的公司的制造总监。捕鲸的结束事实上并不是奈氏润滑剂的终结。捕鲸的结束事实上并不是奈氏润滑剂的终结。随着原材料供应的消失，公司决定：我们自己造。
There's a lubricant that goes in here for the mechanism as you push the top of the inhaler in order to get a dose of medicine. There's also other drug delivery device in here for an insulin application. This one was important because there's a needle involved. D'Ambrosio is director of manufacturing at a company that to this day is still called Nile lubricants. The end of whaling was not, in fact, the end of Nile lubricants. The end of whaling was not, in fact, the end of Nile lubricants. With their supply of raw material gone, the company decided, we'll just make our own.
在大约乔斯报告发布的时候，奈剩下的几名员工开始尝试一种新型润滑剂——不是鲸油，不是石油，而是合成润滑剂，用实验室里调配出来的新型化学品制成。合成意味着该公司可以为特定应用加速设计专用润滑剂，因为现在有太多不同的化学品可以尝试。你知道的，家喻户晓的名字，比如……聚α烯烃，全氟聚醚（也称为PFPE），酯类。酯类可以是双酯。聚亚烷基二醇酯。
Around the time of the Joe's report, Nye's few remaining employees began tinkering with a new type of lubricant, not whale oil, not petroleum, but synthetic lubricant, made with new kinds of chemicals cooked up in the lab. Synthetics meant that the company could turbocharge their designing of specialty lubricants for a particular application, because now there were so many different chemicals to try out. You know, household names like... Polyalfa olefin, peripheralle polyethers, also known as PFPE, esters. Esters could be die esters. Polyallic esters.
还有你的硅油，你正在研究……P.F.P.E.（全氟聚醚）。……从地底下出来的东西。随着世界进入又一个机械时代，这个庞大的新化学库被证明很有用。随着计算机时代的曙光初现，奈氏润滑剂在20世纪末精心制作了定制润滑脂，非常适合让键盘咔嗒作响、打印机打印以及硬盘以每分钟数千转的速度旋转。凭借对合成材料的专注，该公司重新振作起来。今天，他们制造了1000多种不同的润滑剂，每一种都旨在支持我们时代最重要的技术，
And you have your silicone oils where you're looking at... P.F.P.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E.E. out of the ground. And this massive new chemical library proved useful as the world entered yet another machine of Lucien. As the computer era dawned, Nile lubricants spent the late 20th century crafting custom grises that were just right for keeping keyboards clacking, printers printing, and hard drives spinning at thousands of rotations per minute. With a focus on synthetics, the company built itself back up. Today, they make more than 1,000 different lubricants, each designed to enable the most important technologies of our time,
包括目前正在探索火星表面的“毅力号”火星车，同样重要的。这是一个Xbox手柄。所以你用来游戏的所有的按键，这里都需要润滑剂才能使设备工作。这至关重要，因为如果按键开始卡住
including the Perseverance Rover, currently exploring the surface of Mars, and equally important. This one is an Xbox controller. So all of your buttons here for gaming, they require a lubricant in here in order to get the device to work. And it's critical because if the buttons start sticking
并且人们无法正确玩游戏，他们会很不高兴的。让游戏玩家保持高兴是一个与游戏设计本身一样严密的的过程。有很多循环测试，按键实际上需要在特定温度环境中经历承受2000万次按压的考验，以模仿某人坐在那里连续玩六个小时游戏。
and people can't get their games to play correctly, they're not going to be very happy. And keeping gamers happy is a process as rigorous as game design itself. There's a lot of cycle testing where the buttons literally go through needing to survive 20 million pushes in certain temperature environments to mimic someone sitting there playing games for six solid hours.
当你说是2000万次时，那是字面意思吗？字面意思，是的。你是否觉得当你走过这个世界时，你有一种X光视力，你在看物体时会想，里面有润滑脂，就像那个小盒子的铰链上，我的笔记本电脑上有润滑脂，就像，你知道的，你是不是有点像在看这些东西？是的，特别是当事情无法正常工作时。我脑海中浮现的第一件事就是他们没有在里面加入正确的润滑剂，你知道的。
When you said 20 million, was that literal? Literal, yes. Do you feel like when you kind of like move through the world, you have this x-ray vision where you're looking at objects and you're like, there's a grease in there, like on the hinge of that little box, there's a grease on like, you know, my laptop, like are you kind of like seeing these things? Yeah, particularly when things don't work properly. The first thing that comes to my mind is they didn't put the right lubricant in it, you know. Today the world is growing more and more digital, and it may even feel like the mechanical
今天，世界变得越来越数字化，甚至可能会让人觉得威廉·F·奈曾帮助润滑的机械时代正在走向终结，我们对更多更好润滑剂的需求也随之终结。但即使是互联网，感觉与物理世界如此分离，实际上也只是一台拥有数百万个运动部件的巨大机器。容纳我们猫咪照片和银行信息的数据库依赖于冷却系统、压缩机和风扇，所有这些都使用特殊设计的润滑脂。而那些将猫咪照片和银行信息传送到海洋下和跨越大陆的光纤缆车，它们也使用润滑脂来防范不断在我们世界中泛起涟漪的微小振动。
age that William F. and I helped Greece is coming to an end, along with our need for more and better lubricants. But even the internet, which feels so separate from the physical world, is actually just a giant machine with billions of moving parts. The data centers that house our cat photos and banking info rely on cooling systems, compressors and fans that all use specially designed grease. And the fiber optic cables that beam those cat photos and banking info beneath the oceans and across continents, they use grease too to guard against the tiny vibrations constantly rippling across
我们都可以逃到元宇宙，完全抛弃物理世界及其所有的运动部件，所以请不要这样做。我们仍然需要不起眼的润滑脂来保持其运转。在夏天最热、最潮湿的日子里，如果你漫步到奈氏润滑剂生产车间后面的角落，你仍然可以闻到一丝鲸鱼油的味道。从他们使用材料的那时候起，它就已经渗入水泥中，很难去除。
our world. We could all de-camp to the metaverse, completely abandoning the physical world and all its moving parts, so please don't do that. And we'd still need humble grease to keep it running. On the hottest, most humid days of summer, if you wander over to the back corner of the production floor at Nile lubricants, you can still catch a whiff of whale oil. From time that it, you know, when they were working with materially, it just got into the cement and it's difficult to get out.
这不是一种好闻的气味。它非常刺鼻。我不知道，真的怎么把它弄出去。这不是一种好闻的气味。它非常刺鼻。我不知道，真的怎么去形容它。有点像……我不知道。也许像臭脚丫子。这很恶心。但这却是一个有力的提醒：好的润滑脂不是偶然产生的。为了让我们的机器运转，它需要几个世纪的精心设计和开发。尽管威廉·奈进入捕鲸行业时只是在追逐一种时尚，但他偶然发现了一个需求，这个需求将一直持续到时间的尽头。
It's not a good smell. It's very pungent. It's, I don't know, really how to get out. It's not a good smell. It's very pungent. It's, I don't know really how to describe it. It's kind of I don't know. Maybe like sweaty feet. It's it's gross But it's a potent reminder that good grease doesn't happen by accident It's taken centuries of careful design and development to keep armaching his running Even though William Knight was chasing a fad when he got into the whale business, he stumbled upon selling a solution to a problem that would need solving until the end of time.
接下来，新贝德福德最后一位捕鲸人的女儿将讲述在捕鲸业工作的感受——正是这个行业照亮了世界并帮助催生了优质的润滑脂。广告之后见。所以我们回到了记者丹尼尔·阿克曼身边。嘿，丹尼尔。嘿，罗曼。所以我喜欢关于润滑脂的这20分钟节目，这绝对是经典的99号管道节目，关于润滑脂的20分钟。
Coming up, the daughter of New Bedford's last whale man describes what it was like to work in whaling, the industry that lit the world and helped give rise to good Greece. After this. So we're back with reporter Daniel Ackerman. Hey Daniel. Hey Roman. So I loved that 20 minutes on Greece, that's some classic 99 PI stuff right there, 20 minutes on grease.
这太棒了，但我听说你想再多聊聊鲸鱼。没错。其实我想从《白鲸》开始，因为我听说罗曼你是它的粉丝。我是。我是《白鲸》的超级粉丝。好吧。
It was so fantastic, but I hear you want to talk a little bit more about whales. Right. And I actually want to start with Moby Dick because I hear Roman that you're a fan. I am. I am a huge fan of Moby Dick. All right.
每当我的灵魂感到十一月般萧瑟时，我就会阅读《白鲸》的小段落。我甚至喜欢那些枯燥的、充满糟糕鲸鱼生物学知识的章节。我都喜欢。太棒了。好吧，你应该去新贝德福德参加一次《白鲸》马拉松，这正如它的名字所暗示的那样。
Whenever it's November in my soul, I read little passages of Moby Dick. I even like those boring chapters with really bad whale biology. I like it all. Nice. Well, you should come to New Bedford one year for the Moby Dick marathon, which is exactly what it sounds like.
人们只是聚在一起，坐下来大声朗读，从头到尾读完整本《白鲸》。通常需要大约25个小时，所以带点咖啡吧。我会非常喜欢这个。你根本想象不到。我不喝咖啡。是的，所以我的意思是，这吸引了成百上千的人，即使捕鲸的年代早已过去，新贝德福德与海洋之间仍然有着这种非常紧密的联系。
People just get together and sit around and read aloud, cover to cover the entirety of Moby Dick. Usually takes about 25 hours, so bring some coffee. I would be so into that. You have no idea. I wouldn't eat coffee. Yeah, so I mean, this jaws hundreds of people, there's still this like really strong connection
不过新贝德福德仍然是一个大型渔港。它实际上是该国收入最高的渔港，但今天他们捕捞的是扇贝，而不是鲸鱼。没错，所以捕捞扇贝不需要鱼叉。没有鱼叉，你得去捕鲸博物馆看那些，但我确实有一个关于那些使用鱼叉的人的故事要讲给你听。这些可不是像威廉·F·奈这样的捕鲸业老板。这些是真正冒着生命危险去公海捕捉这些动物的人，正是这些动物为世界提供了光明和润滑剂。
between New Bedford and the sea, even though the wailing days are long gone. New Bedford is still a big fishing port though. It's actually the highest grossing fishing port in the country, but today they catch scallops, not whales. Right, so no harpoons required for scallops. No harpoons, you'll have to go to the Whaling Museum to see those, but I do have a story for you about the people who used those harpoons. And these aren't the whale business owners like William F. Nye. These are the folks that actually risked their lives out on the high seas to catch these animals that provided the world with light and lubricant.
所以在这里我想向你介绍一个人。我叫多萝西·洛佩斯。我住在新贝德福德。我在新贝德福德出生长大，而且现在还在这里。依然在新贝德福德，已经88岁高龄了，我去找多萝西是为了听她讲讲她的父亲，安东尼奥·洛伦佐·洛佩斯。那么安东尼奥·洛伦佐·洛佩斯是谁呢？好吧，他于1897年出生在西非海岸外佛得角群岛的一个小镇上。
So here I want to introduce you to someone. My name is Dorothy Lopes. I live in New Bedford. I was born and raised in New Bedford, and I'm still here. Still in New Bedford at 88 years of age, and I went to talk to Dorothy to hear about her father, Antonio Lorenzo Lopes. So who is Antonio Lorenzo Lopes? Well, he was born in 1897 in a small town in the Cape Verde islands off the west coast of Africa.
十几岁时，安东尼奥开始和身为渔夫的父亲一起工作。他们俩买了一些木材。他们建造了一艘小船代替船桨。然后安东尼奥学会了如何划船。他们抓乌龟和小杂鱼。主要是，那是他们抓的东西。什么是小杂鱼？是一种小鱼，大概六到七英寸长。我猜它们非常美味。
And as a teenager, Antonio went to work with his father, who was a fisherman. The two of them bought some lumber. They built a small boat instead of ores. And Antonio learned how to row it. They caught turtles and scum. Mainly, that was what they caught. What are scum? It's a small fish, six to seven inches maybe. I guess they were very tasty.
我只能听信他们的话，刺太多了。我不喜欢有刺的鱼。所以是那种又小又多刺的鱼。这就像是佛得角的一种父子渔业生意。他们一直坚持这样做，直到有一天，安东尼奥二十出头时，一个家庭朋友找到了他，那个人只比他大一点点。他曾乘捕鲸船去过美国，在返回佛得角时，他经常对我的父亲说：“你知道的，你应该去美国，你应该去美国，我会帮你弄到船票的。”
I took their word to me, I had too many bones. I didn't like fish with bones. So small, bony fish. This was just like kind of a father-son fishing business in Cape Verde. And they kept at this for a few years until one day when Antonio was in his early 20s and he was approached by a family friend, someone who was just a bit older than him. And he had been to America on wheeling ships and going back to Cape Verde, he used to talk to my dad about, you know, you should come to America, you should come to America, I'll get you
就像这是美国捕鲸业的常见做法。他们会去佛得角或亚速尔群岛等地招募工人，因为这些地方拥有高技能的劳动力。像安东尼奥这样的人都是划手，他们花了数年时间在这些小划艇上驾驭开阔的海洋。
on a boat. And like this was common practice in the American whaling industry. They would go out and recruit workers in places like Cape Verde or the Azores Islands, because those places had this highly skilled labor. People like Antonio were Oarsmen who had spent years navigating the open ocean in these small robos.
好吧，那么捕鲸船上的划手的工作到底是什么呢？没错。所以，也许从宏观角度来看，捕鲸远征是如何运作的。大多数时候，安东尼奥只是和船员们一起在这个带有桅杆、船帆和一切的大型帆船上闲逛。桅杆顶部的瞭望台里会有几个人，时刻监视着水面，对吧？
Okay, so what exactly is the job of an orzman on a wailing ship then? Right. So so maybe like big picture like how the wailing expedition worked. Most of the time, um, Antonio was just like hanging around with the crew on this big sailing ship with masks and sales and everything. And there would be a couple guys up on top of the mast in the crow's nest, keeping a watch on the water, right?
当那些观察员在远处看到一头鲸鱼时，他们会大喊，罗曼，那是什么？鲸喷气孔。鲸喷气孔。那是对身为划手的安东尼奥来说可以行动的信号。所以他会做的是，他会和几个其他划手以及船上的鱼叉手挤在一起，然后他们都会跳进这艘小得多、更灵活的划艇里，然后他们这一群人会被放下去冲浪去追赶鲸鱼。
And when those spotters saw a whale out in the distance, they would yell, what are they, El Roman? The Darcy blows. The Darcy blows. That was the signal that it was go time for Antonio as the Orsman. So what he would do is he would huddle up with a couple other Orsman in the ship's harpooner, and then they would all jump into this much smaller, more nimble robot and then the group of them would get lowered down into
你知道每当我想起这件事，我就会不寒而栗，因为尽管我的父亲住在一个岛上，但他不会游泳。所以我想象我的父亲和船上的其他男人一起在广阔的大海外面。我不知道他们是否会游泳。他们没有救生衣之类的东西。所以，我想，哦天哪，他是那些多次跳下捕鲸船进入这些小船去追赶鲸鱼却幸存下来的幸运儿之一。
the surf to go after the whale. You know when I think about it, I just get shivers because even the my father lived on an island, he did not know how to swim. So I think of my father out on this huge ocean with other men in the boat with him. I don't know if they know how to swim. They didn't have life jackets and things of that nature. So, I thought, oh my God, he was one of the lucky ones who survived all those times, you know, jumping off the wheeling ship
这对我来说太神奇了，他不会游泳。如果那是我的工作，我会投入一些时间去学习游泳。是的，但他，我的意思是，他就是去了。他划着这艘微小而灵活的小船出去追赶鲸鱼，并让它进入鱼叉手开枪的位置。多萝西说，这对所有相关人员来说都是最危险的时刻。鲸鱼开始在水中翻滚。她说有大量的血，大量的血，我可以想象。然后他们必须把鲸鱼拖到大船旁边，接着他们就会开始切割鲸鱼的过程。所以他们切割鲸鱼
into these small boats to go chase the whales. That is amazing to me that he didn't know how to swim. I would, I would invest some time in learning how to swim if that was my job. Yeah, but he, I mean, he just went for it. He rode this like tiny nimble boat out to chase the whale and get it into position for the harpooner to take a shot. And Dorothy said like this was the moment that was the most dangerous for everyone involved. The whale would start turning over and over in the water. He said there was lots of blood, lots of blood I could imagine. And then they would have to tow the whale up alongside of the large ship and then they would start the process of cutting up the whale. And so they cut up the whale
就像当它还在水中时，在船边，对吗？是的，他们会把它沿着船拖过来，他们会把它翻过船舷，一块一块地卸下鲸脂，然后他们会把每一块鲸脂煮沸成鲸油。整个过程可能需要数天才能完成
like when it's still in the water, like alongside the ship, correct? Yeah, they would like tow it along the ship, they would like over the side, lock off the blubber chunk by chunk, and then they would boil each of those chunks down into the whale oil. And this whole process could take days
对于一头鲸鱼来说，船员们需要夜以继日地工作。剥下鲸脂后，鲸鱼的其余部分怎么样了？是的，一旦他们得到了鲸脂，他们通常就会让大部分尸体沉回海洋中。有时他们确实会保留一些骨头。水手们会把它们雕刻成叫做“牙雕”的艺术品。其中一些实际上非常令人印象深刻地精细。捕鲸人会把它们带回家作为送给女朋友或家人的礼物。多萝西还告诉我，有时他们会从鲸鱼身上挽救一些肉，并将其磨成汉堡包。这尤其重要，对船员来说可能是一种享受，因为除此之外，船上没有太多东西可供多萝西的父亲和船员食用。
to complete for a single whale with the man working 24-7. And after they took off the blubber, what happened to the rest of the whale? Yeah, so once they got the blubber, they would often just let most of the carcass go to sink back down into the ocean. Sometimes they did keep some of the bones. The sailors would carve them into these art pieces called scrimshaw. Some of those are actually really impressively elaborate. The whalers would bring them home as gifts for their girlfriends or families or whatever. Dorothy also told me sometimes they'd salvage some of the meat from the whale and they would
我们总是谈论面包。厨师做的面包。它就像一个坚硬的外壳，几乎像一个饼干。所以每天，你都有面包和糖蜜。你在描述那个饼干时做了一个鬼脸。
grind that into hamburgers. This was particularly important and probably a treat for the crew because otherwise there was not much on the ship for Dorothy's father in the crew to eat. We always talked about bread. The cook made bread. It was like a hard crusty, but almost like a biscuit. So every day, and you have bread and molasses. You're making a face when you're describing that biscuit.
我无法想象吃它。你知道，好多天，是的，我的意思是，你在外面呆了好几个月，你吃着面包和这种糖蜜，也许有时你还有这种磨碎的鲸鱼肉。所以只吃面包、糖蜜和鲸鱼肉并不是一个真正的均衡饮食。是的，但是听着，罗曼。这也是捕鲸业故事的关键所在。多萝西说，在这艘捕鲸船的厨房里，藏着一堆饱满、多汁、美味的橙子。但安东尼奥和船员们并没有得到橙子。
I can't imagine eating it. You know, for days, yeah, I mean, you're out there months and you've got bread in this molasses and maybe sometimes you have this ground whale meat. So it's not a really balanced diet eating only bread molasses and whale meat. No, but get this, Roman. And here's kind of the crux of the story of the whaling industry. Dorothy says that in the galley, in the kitchen of this whaling ship, there was this stash of plump, juicy, delicious oranges. But Antonio and the crew, they didn't get the oranges.
他们得到的是橙皮，这些橙皮被晒干了，他们可以用开水煮着喝，做成一种茶。那谁得到了橙子？可能是船长。还有大副和那些人，船上的军官。这让我想起了《白鲸》中的一段话，我最喜欢的段落之一，关于船上谁能吃到黄油晚餐，你知道船长得到了黄油，然后随着你顺着指挥链往下走，
They'd get the skin of the oranges, which was dried, and they could boil it with water to make a kind of tea. And then who got the oranges? Probably the captain. And the first mate and those people, officers on the ship. This reminds me of a passage in Moby Dix, one of my favorite passages, about who on the boat got to eat butter for dinner and and you know the captain gets butter and then as you go down the chain of command
最终传到了弗拉斯克，他没有得到黄油，里面有我《白鲸》中最喜欢的一句话：“弗拉斯克，哎呀，是一个没有黄油的人。”是的，没有黄油，也没有橙子，经济上也是如此。是的，我确信他也没有得到橙子。是的，也许，也许在下一期节目中，罗曼，你应该把整本书大声读给我们听。太棒了，特洛伊。别引诱我。
eventually gets down to flask who does not get butter and it has one of my favorite sentences in all of Moby Dick which was flask alas was a butterless man. Yeah butterless and orange and orangeless, financially. Yeah I'm sure he didn't get oranges either. Yeah maybe maybe for the next episode, Roman, you should just read the whole book aloud for us. That's great, Troy. Don't tempt me.
但事情就是这样。这实际上是一次成功的远征。他们捕获了几条鲸鱼，但在这一切结束时，安东尼奥得到的除了那些橙皮之外，所剩无几。当他们离开佛得角时，直到六个月后才到达新贝德福德，他有10美元。他在六个月的时间里赚了10美元？10美元。
But that's how it went. And this was actually a successful expedition. They caught several whales, but at the end of it all, Antonio was left with not much more than those orange peels. When they left Cape Verde, and Cain didn't get to New Bedford until six months later, he had $10. He made $10 over the course of six months? $10.
但事情就是这样。这其实是一次成功的探险。他们捕获了好几头鲸鱼，但到头来，安东尼奥得到的除了那些橘子皮之外，所剩无几。当他们离开佛得角时，凯恩直到六个月后才到达新贝德福德，他身上只有10美元。他在六个月里只赚了10美元？10美元。
Whatever any supplies that you got, like at first they say they gave you two shirts, two pairs of overalls, pair of shoes, a hat, like a rain type, slicker type of coat. And, yeah, but they took it out of whatever you were making that was taken out. So at the end of six months, he had made $10. So $10. Can you remind me of what year this is again? Yeah. So this is around 1920. So in today's dollars, that would be like making 150 bucks. For half of a year's work. Yeah. For half a year's work. And Dorothy says her, that would be like making 150 bucks. For half of a year's work.
不管你拿到什么补品，一开始他们说给你两件衬衫、两条工装裤、一双鞋、一顶帽子，就像那种雨衣、油布大衣一样的。而且，对，但这些都要从你赚的钱里扣除。所以到六个月结束时，他赚了10美元。就10美元。你能提醒我这是哪一年吗？对。所以这是在1920年左右。所以用今天的美元来算，那就像赚了150块钱。为了半年的工作。对。为了半年的工作。多萝西说她，那就像赚了150块钱。为了半年的工作。
Yeah, for half a year's work. And Dorothy says her father wasn't even that badly off compared to some of the other whalers. The stories of Whelman, among the Cape Veridian Whelman, who came back from several months of whaling, owing the captain money, I believe is because they were people of color and taken advantage of another farmer's slavery. So what did Antonio do when he arrived in New Bedford? Did he stay in the wailing business? Well, so this was getting into the 1920s and commercial wailing was really on his last legs. So instead,
是的，为了半年的工作。多萝西说，与一些其他捕鲸人相比，她父亲的处境甚至算不上最糟的。威尔曼的故事，在佛得角裔捕鲸人当中，他们出海捕鲸几个月回来后，反而欠了船长钱，我相信这是因为他们是有色人种，受到了另一种农奴制的剥削。那么安东尼奥来到新贝德福德后做了什么？他留在捕鲸行业了吗？嗯，所以当时已经进入20世纪20年代，商业捕鲸确实已经日薄西山。所以相反，
and commercial whaling was really on his last legs. So instead, Antonio took a job at a factory that made nails. And in his first week at that factory, he made $17. Wow. So more than he made in the entire whaling expedition, like $7 more than he made whaling for an entire half of a year. That's amazing. Yeah. So that was definitely the end of whaling for Antonio.
而且商业捕鲸确实已经日薄西山。所以相反，安东尼奥去了一家制造钉子的工厂找了一份工作。在那家工厂的第一周，他赚了17美元。哇。所以这比他在整个捕鲸探险中赚的还要多，比他整整半年捕鲸赚的钱还要多出大约7美元。太惊人了。是的。所以对安东尼奥来说，这绝对是捕鲸生涯的结束。
He never went back out to sea. But I think his story captures a lot about how whaling worked. And by the way, this whole history of whaling and the workers who built the industry is still really present today. And if you walk around New Bedford, the industry drew people from all over the world and to take Dorothy's family history as an example, the city is still a huge part of the Cape Verdean diaspora. You'll see Cape Verdean flags in front of houses. The Cape Verdean Prime Minister makes state visits to New Bedford from time to time. Oh wow. And that connection, like so much of the culture in the city, goes back to the time when people came here to chase whales
他再也没有出海。但我觉得他的故事很大程度上反映了捕鲸业是如何运作的。顺便说一句，这段捕鲸的历史以及建立这个行业的工人们，直到今天依然历历在目。如果你在纽贝德福德走一走，这个行业吸引了来自世界各地的人，以多萝西的家族史为例，这座城市至今仍是佛得角侨民的重要聚居地。你会在房屋前看到佛得角的国旗。佛得角总理时不时会对纽贝德福德进行国事访问。哦，哇。这种联系，就像这座城市的许多文化一样，可以追溯到人们来到这里追逐鲸鱼的时代
with a dream that did not always pan out. Well, I love hearing about this history. I really appreciate it. I'm so glad the whaling industry is dead and gone and we're not killing these animals anymore, but I love hearing about the past of it. So thank you so much, Dan. I appreciate it. Anytime I smell, I mean, Roman. 99% Invisible With Produced This Week by Daniel Accommon and Jacob Moltenado Medina. Daniel first reported a version of this story for C.A.I. Radio, mixed by Martin Gonzales, music by Swan Rial. Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kurt Colstead is our digital director.
怀揣着并非总能实现的梦想。嗯，我喜欢听这段历史。我真的很感激。我很高兴捕鲸业已经消亡，我们不再猎杀这些动物了，但我喜欢听它的过去。所以非常感谢你，丹。我很感激。每当我闻到，我是说罗曼。本周的节目由丹尼尔·阿科曼和雅各布·莫尔特纳多·梅迪纳制作。丹尼尔最初为C.A.I.电台报道了这个故事的一个版本，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里亚尔创作。德兰妮·霍尔是我们高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们数字总监。
The rest of the team includes Vivian Leigh, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Chris Baroube, Jason De Leon, Lashemadon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Sophia Clatsker, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks to Ann Marie Lopes and the New Bedford Wailing National Historic Park. 99% of visible is part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered
团队的其他成员包括维维安·李、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、拉谢马顿、约瑟夫·罗森伯格、凯利·普莱姆、索菲亚·克拉茨克以及我罗曼·马尔斯。99%的隐形标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。特别感谢安妮·玛丽·洛佩斯和新贝德福德捕鲸国家历史公园。99%的隐形是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在
six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love
潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。而且很漂亮。奥克兰市中心，加利福尼亚州。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上@我 Roman Mars，也可以@节目 99PI org。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接
as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99pid. dot org. at 99pi.org. Comey Ishmael. Some years ago, never mind how long precisely, having little or no money in my purse and nothing particular to interest me on shore, I thought I would sail about a little and see the watery part of the world. It is a way I have of driving off the spleen and regulating the circulation. Whenever I find myself growing grim about the mouth, whenever it is a damp, drizzly November in my soul.
以及99PI的每一期往期节目，网址是99pid.dot.org。在99pi.org。伊什梅尔呼唤我。几年前，具体记不清有多久了，我口袋里几乎没有钱，岸上也特に没有什么让我感兴趣的事，我以为我可以到处航行一下，看看世界水域。这是我驱散脾气、调节血液循环的一种方式。每当我发现自己嘴角紧绷，每当我灵魂中出现潮湿、毛毛雨的十一月时。
Whenever I find myself involuntarily pausing before coffin warehouses and bringing up the rear of every funeral I meet, and especially whenever my hypos get such an upper hand of me that it requires a strong moral principle to prevent me from deliberately stepping into the street and methodically knocking people's hats off, then I count it high time to get to stichr as soon as I can. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
每当我发现自己不由自主地在棺材仓库前驻足，走在我遇到的每一次葬礼的队伍后面时，尤其是每当我忧郁情绪发作到需要极强的道德原则才能阻止自己故意走上街头并有条不紊地打掉别人的帽子时，我就认为该尽快去stichr了。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。